pasó los metros de territorio
estadounidense en Ciudad Juárez en la
frontera con México miles de migrantes
intentan cruzar a Estados Unidos
entre ellos hay muchos venezolanos que
huyen de la escasez y la pobreza en su
propio país
pero una medida conocida como título 42
adoptada bajo la administración de Trump
que hace posible la devolución de
migrantes incluidos los solicitantes de
asilo y que se suponía expiraría el
miércoles por la noche fue confirmada
por la Corte Suprema de mayoría
conservadora una noticia que generó
preocupación
a la expectativa porque quedan una
noticia
dan una noticia y después a la media
hora sueltan otra noticia Entonces así
estamos pues no no sabemos no sabemos
nada nos dicen que se extendió hasta el
27 pero no hay una respuesta del juez
directa pues me entiende no hay nada
oficial Entonces hasta que no haya nada
oficial tenemos que estar aquí muchos
han estado aquí durante semanas
soportando temperaturas bajo cero uno
que tiene su familia y quería sacar sus
hijos adelante no puede pasar no puede
ingresar y otra cosa estamos en Navidad
muchos están compartiendo con su familia
uno se tuvo que venir fuera de su
familia
y sus hijos pues no necesitan Pues hay
un 24 de diciembre que tú no sabes dónde
van a dormir en el periodo entre la
introducción del título 42 en marzo de
2020 y el pasado septiembre a los
migrantes de América Latina y el Caribe
se les ha negado el asilo dos coma tres
millones de veces en la frontera sur de
Estados Unidos con el futuro de esta
política a un incierto muchos
continuarán su espera aquí